j'ai rencontré en fait un homme
politique à travers cyril hanouna et je
me suis dit tiens si quelqu'un pouvait
incarner le glissement de notre
démocratie vers autre chose
vers un président divertissant à la
trump ce serait lui
[Musique]
le président c'est d'abord la rencontre
entre deux univers donc l'univers de
julien qui est un jeune communicants
briand qui sort de sciences po et qui
est parachuté par vincent bolloré dans
l'univers de cyril hanouna dont qui part
il part de ces démonstrations en trois
points extrêmement classique et il
arrive dans un univers où on l'appelle
mon chéri et c c'est un choc culturel
total pour lui l'idée de la bd elle est
venue de mon passage en plateau chez
cyril hanouna j'avais été appelé pour
commenter une actualité et j'ai
rencontré en fait un homme politique à
travers cyril hanouna et je me suis dit
tiens si quelqu'un pouvait incarner le
glissement de notre démocratie vers
autre chose
vers un président divertissant à la
trump ce serait lui et on autre thèse
avec morgan navarro dans notre bd c'est
que c'est possible c'est à dire qu'on
est mûr pour passer à un président
divertissant avant d'être un bon
président compétent
[Musique]
il est plus investie qu'un autre serait
pas été possible avec drucker avec
patrick sébastien avec toute l'ancienne
génération avec hanouna qui à la fois
producteur de son émission propriétaire
entre guillemets un de plusieurs chaînes
appuyé par un énorme partie qui est en
quelque sorte d'un sens bolloré c'est
c'est quelque chose de digne d'unique en
fait dans l'histoire française
il suffirait qu'ils veuillent un peu
comme beppe grillo l'a voulu en italie
zélande ce qu'il a voulu en outre et en
ukraine
trump la volée aux etats-unis fin on a
beaucoup d'exemples aujourd'hui
alors moi j'ai pas du tout candidat à un
poste de conseiller en communication de
cyril hanouna
moi je ne serais pas ce communicant la
sec un communicant ne normalement il a
des valeurs aussi démocratique on est
comme tout le monde mais il ya une
frange des communicants qui seraient
prêts à peu près à tout pour prendre une
sorte de revanche est au fond faire
aboutir leurs candidats et y en a
beaucoup des profils comme ça alors
cyril hanouna a aimé la bd ses
chroniqueurs disque on l'entend parler
dans la bd c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment lui donc ce qui prouve qu'on a
au moins bien fait notre travail dans
kate lui a aimé oui parce que c'est la
première fois si vous voulez qu'on on
traite cette hypothèse sérieusement
c'est là qu'on le prend au sérieux et au
fond chez tous les clowns chez tous les
gens qui font du divertissement il ya
avant tout quelqu'un de sérieux
quelqu'un qui réfléchit la bd s'ouvre
sur chasse et n'importe qui aujourd'hui
peut devenir président de la république
[Musique]